was kannst du eigentlich
junge du machst doch kein bisschen mit
vize posten und die [ __ ] arbeit
generate es muss etwas getan werden
generell okay dafür brauchen wir drei
rief ein batterie und die batterie dafür
brauchen wir noch ein iron fällen ist
macht man sich dann nochmals ein feines
mein gott ich mache die ganze zeit alles
mit danach machst du verlierst sich dann
noch mal so dann mach ich ja aber ich
bin informiert ich mache arbeit wäre es
überhaupt als ermöglicht bekommt später
wir brauchen doch gar kein drama mehr
natürlich ist auch viel aber machen die
sache jetzt gerade eine woche für alles
kupferkabel für alles später glaube mir
reingekommen guckt mich an
ja dann hören wir uns natürlich viel
besser wenn wir und wenn wir
nebeneinander stehen in minecraft sowas
nicht an welche die rede
die fristen rede mit dem schaf richtig
lachen
hab ich doch vielleicht das 32 das video
ja kommen
alessandra city und du hast weiß das
auch nicht gemacht hast das mitreden
ja ich weiß aber den habe ich extra
nicht vorgestellt weil bei der hunderter
tnt bombe ist das schon alles abgestürzt
marcell minecraft deswegen dachten die
kommt steht nicht vor
es gibt da war das da trotzdem dann alle
so traurig drüber sind so wir brauchen
noch ein kupferkabel das heißt wir
brauchen noch hast du noch aber ich bin
dabei hier professionell aber
anzupflanzen muss meint eigentlich hin
hast du mein twitter youtube oder ja der
kiste vorn im haus diese kiste stehen
links da vorne von links vom eingang
werkzeugkisten herms der bei viele items
sind ist unglaublich hier
ich verzeihe mir machen halt einfach mal
sondern sonne 20 minuten folge ruft
einfach mal das ist das wird das hat die
bauform es sieht echt schön aus so
verbaut dass mal weg gaddafis will das
auch dabei dass nirgendwo direktlinks
dran
das war blöd naja ich laufe dann wieder
mal in den wald hinten haben wir klasse
grad dann tatsächlich etwas wollen ich
habe doch noch mehr du bist viel näher
am haus erst recht aber noch im schönen
verordnetes fleisch übrigens habe ich
noch mal nachgeguckt du warst du hast
jetzt mal gesagt dass du veganer sein
willst in venedig ich hab gesagt ich hab
gesagt vegetarier hier in minecraft weil
das könnte ja niemals mit oder so
trinken hier ja okay stimmt ich habe
übrigens auch leder was kommen sie nur
mit leder machen mitglieder genau
werderaner dann darf soll nicht in den
entscheid mit table benutzen der besteht
ja auch aus leder
richtig happy end im echten leben ist
nicht nur noch kein echter so kalt wie
liferay und leute schaut euch das mal
bitte an was was sind das hierfür sachen
was bringt uns das die tisch dessen
einfache blöcke die hier rumstehen weil
man kann das mit nichts gegen die
abbauen also was bringen uns diese
blöcke hier wo ich gerade drauf stehen
das verstehe ich nicht
na ja und hier besonders an sonnen
sondern so eine schöne ecke echt ob wir
von euch einfach ins spiel dass ich mich
sehr sehr schön aufnehmen sieht
wunderschön aus
ich mache jetzt habe ich in jeder folge
man so ein spiel schott was sind das
denn die fünf bauern von dem einst jeder
folge man screenshot weil er keine
textur infekt ich mache jeder folgendes
spiel statt damit ich nicht nachher beim
server fliegen muss sondern immer so ein
screenshot habt ihr für die folge auch
passt so was das für ein holz das ist
rage wird alter ich würde sagen wir
machen das doch aus braidwood die ganzen
fehler sieht der begrüßen wir haben den
kompletten bauabfällen dass es so ein
bisschen lila lila braun passten wir uns
gut
ich meine wir können das haus ja immer
noch oder wir können sondern zweites
haus bauen möchte sagen dass erst mal
zusammen wohnen bleiben immer zusammen
bleiben damit wir uns alle items
aufteilen können und am besten halt noch
keine ärztin zukunft irgendwie
verbrennen weil wir haben dann natürlich
die skater und elektrik fellners und
kombination kommt mehr raus wie findet
ihr ab ich hab' ich hab hier welche ihm
die schon alle mit anpacken damit du dir
also erstens zeug draußen und dann
abhaken damit du die brauchen wir
beschuldigt
sind wir noch da sind kommen hier ist
das ist das eine
das paradoxe daran stunde
vallendar ganz normal auf setzlinge raus
hatten einfach kaputt und dann jetzt war
die schere mitgenommen doch besser
glaube ich oder ein stück wachsen so
schnell einfach dings djk rohr
knochenmehl zu kampf mit zuckerbrot sind
dabei gefällt aber schon der befristete
visier runter fällt mir sogar auf ich
habe schon 64 grad freuen wenn viele von
den schatten setzen kannst du denn weil
ihr verfallen fast gar keine setzlingen
runter ich habe gar keine mehr aber ich
habe ja selber ich auch angefasst
gleicher weise bekommen können jedoch
meist an bord
hier fallen echt keine selbst und doch
dass ein setzling konnten wir selber
hier dann kannst du dir will es auf die
harte tour startet ok du willst du ja
was denn was meine mutter meine mutter
ja gedacht sich außer acht der hat
bestimmt wird zehnmal mehr lohn nicht
millionen euro profi make you were weiß
es ist schlecht das ist schlimm
es macht mir einen job dann nehme ich
die zu hinten an die 8 klatsche ich hier
richtig an den arsch du musst sie aber
festhalten aber yacht ist darf sich
runter kommen das kann uns keiner von
diesen bäume aber im sumpfgebiet von
hinten jetzt selber welche anfassen also
ich habe vier setzlinge für dich
damit kann ich erst mal arbeiten möchte
wenigstens etwas
für doch sagen wir machen uns vorne sein
kleines blumenbeet wem sowas von viele
verschiedene arten von blumen die ich
immer zwischendurch so sehe
hector berlioz sind zwei schläge mit dem
zafira werden diese alle down hey ich
hab ihn steht ist auch nicht schlecht
bezahlte moderneres ob das genauso gut
technologien smaragd gibt es noch was
mag da sind zum traden smaragd sind zum
traden der baum schon so schön geredet
ja warte ich gibt eben dieses dankeschön
vielen dank vier stück vor dass er
richtig was rausgeholt
ja da haben nicht mehr runter ich meine
ich ernst viel viel schon gut also finde
schon nicht schlecht
schon kinder typ dürfte das war hier das
andere holz aber das hat deshalb nicht
in der textur von links von sechs aber
guck dir das mal an das wäre glaube ich
in der simon weiteres sah ich komme das
licht in den tunnel und das ist halt das
blöde sau weiteres meg whitman
ja aber es trotzdem nicht darum
vorhanden daneben ist nicht das was ihr
da liegen ja dann mitgenommen smaragde
sind zum traden
wartet so wir müssen jetzt erst mal
bücher machen und dann bücherregale und
dann orgel wird jetzt schrecklich
starter ist mitglieder zwei schaufel
kaputt über lena erfolg wollte ich das
erstmal machen die batterie wo ich
machen soll westlich mapa cable astra
verbrennen ich gehe auf die reihe man
redet mir wieder dazwischen was ein
wunder her ich gehe auf die reise jetzt
dinge zu holen
dieses schönen holte mich unter dach
entweder zu kriegen kann
ich habe auch immer gedacht sieht man wo
bisher konstant unser haus rein hatte
bleibt mein brot gesucht richtig finde
ok kommen also schauen wir werden doch
das hier unten aus diesem komischen s
fitch mitternacht aus diesem komischen
stein hier gemacht aber genau da oben
haben das ist das holz war mir das
wirklich zu lassen weil von außen sieht
das relativ komisch aus und von hier
genau er damals da unten die unterste
seite stein und dann holzt nein nein
nein das wir haben das hier unten ja
auch so stone briggs gemacht der inhalt
analogen haben wir das aus holz gemacht
dass holzbalken wo wir das nicht auch
was den fix machen und dann darüber dass
holz oder visum oder wollen wir zulassen
oder keine ahnung sondern ausprobieren
mit den austria dann machen wir es so ja
am besten nur dass wir uns irgendeine
leid dass du das wird auf jeden fall
erstmal peggy riedel erkennt kannst du
dich storm fix machen ich will dieses
dunkle holz genau auch für
expeditionsreise holz auf jeden fall ist
matt stone tricks kann ich machen ja
dann musst du dieses dunkle holz holen
muss schon welches das ist halt ne